joined now by the minister for the
middle east and africa james cleverley
representing the government this morning
hello to you mr cleverley thank you for
joining us on the programme um what is
the plan to save the gas industry
well quasi curtin the
energy
minister the business minister has had a
series of meetings with uh the industry
to ensure
that the uh consumers in here in the uk
are protected and they're protected both
from
uh the increase potentially in gas
prices through the energy price cap that
we have in place but also to ensure that
we have continuity of supply and the
message that he's put out and he put out
a series of tweets that people can look
at if they wish to
is that because of the mix of where we
get our energy from we are in a better
place than many other countries that are
also feeding the pinch from this
increase in wholesale gas supply
and that we will absolutely do
everything we can to protect consumers
to make sure we have a vibrant
energy supply market
55 businesses i believe in the sector
according to this morning's uh front
page of the financial times there could
only be six to ten left by the end of
the year that according to the industry
this is pretty grim stuff
well as i say uh the the business
secretary has
already
had a series of meetings uh he will be
having others i am certain
and what we are doing is working to
ensure that we do two things and that is
to protect consumers from what has been
a a global increase in gas prices
but also to ensure the
security of energy supply and energy
provision
to those consumers and
we're in a pretty good place here in the
uk because of course we have our own
domestic gas supply
but we also receive gas from really very
reliable partners like norway for
example so we're in a better place than
many other countries around the world
will the government bear like small
suppliers who are in danger of going
bust
well as i say the the business secretary
has had and will continue to have
meetings with the sector
the priority is to make sure that we
protect provision for consumers and to
ensure that they aren't hit by
uh
unforeseeable or unpredictable a
significant increase in gas prices
and and those discussions will be
ongoing exactly how we do that will be
up for uh discussion of course but those
are our priorities so that's not on no
then is it i mean if if we see all these
businesses starting to potentially go
bust in order to try to protect people's
gas supplies the government's going to
have to step in and help them aren't
there
well as i say i'm not going to speculate
as to exactly how
we do this but i can assure you that the
conversations that the business
secretary has already had
have been very uh productive and we will
ensure we will ensure the protection of
consumers as i say from the price
inflation that we're seeing all over the
world but also we're very
very conscious of the importance of uh
protecting that energy supply as well
so again the article that i'm referring
to i'm sure you've seen it on the front
of the ft this morning talks about a
northern style
bad bank where um if there are lots of
people whose gas suppliers are going
under they all need to be put under one
umbrella protected by the state in order
to make sure that all of the other
businesses don't go under as well i'm
guessing that just gov good governance
means that you have to be looking at
something like that
well as i say we're we're considering
the options and i'm i'm not
uh i'm not gonna you know speculate as
to exactly how we addressed this but
we've moved quickly the business
secretaries say has already had a series
of meetings uh about this both last week
uh and over the weekend and we've got a
very clear idea of what our priorities
need to be in terms of protecting
consumers and protecting uh the security
of our energy supply so you're not
ruling it out then
okay you keep asking me and i keep
giving you the same answer we are
considering a range of options the
business sector has met with the uh um
the energy supply companies and our
priorities are to protect consumers and
also to protect the security of our
energy supply and we'll look we'll look
at a range of options no doubt but i'm
not going to rule anything in or commit
to anything here on
your show this morning i'm afraid okay
let me drive from a different angle i'm
sure my viewers very anxious this
morning about what's going to happen as
far as their gas is concerned if they or
energy bills are concerned when they
hear that of 55 companies only six out
of six to ten could be left standing by
the end of the year
how
potentially might the public be expected
to pay for that there is a an energy
price cap of 139 pounds for next month
um could that go higher
well the energy price cap is there not
to
uh completely prevents
energy prices ever going up but it's
about making sure that there are no
sudden unexpected unpredictable
big hikes in prices so the energy price
cap has always been designed
designed to move gently upwards but the
big thing is to prevent
as i say big unpredictable spikes in
consumer prices the other thing of
course that the government has put in
there's a whole series of
measures to protect the poorest families
uh in the country through things like um
[Music]
winter
winter fuel support
and also to make it easier for people to
switch providers to get the best deals
so as i say our priority remains to
protect consumers and also to protect
the security of our energy supply so
just clarify that 139 pound lift
cap for next month that is going to stay
at that until six months time when you
look at it again
yeah as i say it's about providing
predictability
for consumers and that the energy price
cap policy is in place it has protected
hundreds of thousands of consumers
already and will continue to do so okay
how worried are we about food supplies
um and the like and concerns about
carbon dioxide it's a little bit
complicated but just for the benefit of
our viewers this morning um we haven't
got enough carbon dioxide it could mean
that
animal husbandry is a challenge over the
next couple of weeks and also some
operations within the nhs and i found it
surprising that you need carbon dioxide
for some nhs hospital operations
apparently but but you do um
what is being put in place by the
government to make sure that that supply
is sorted out
well the
the the points that you raise uh once
again we find ourselves
in a situation that many countries in
the world are experiencing um the
the logistics industry which underpins a
lot of the movement of uh products like
co2 we we know the uh the situation
there and what we're looking to do is
twofold firstly is to make sure that in
the in the medium term and beyond that
the uk is increasingly self-sufficient
in terms of things like food production
but also in terms of uh people in the
logistics change that chain hgb drivers
that kind of stuff
and in the shorter term obviously we are
looking across government at what we
need to do to address what might be some
uh short-term shortages in these things
again these are things that we're
discussing we're discussing with the
industry we discuss them across
government
and we will ensure that we are able to
put food on the tables obviously that is
a real priority
and as i say we're looking across
government and how we address this okay
so alex sharma has been talking about it
as you say you've quoted him several
times during the course of the interview
he's pretty relaxed about things at the
moment prime minister on his way to new
york less relaxed saying that there will
be some supply shortages where are you
sitting on that scale
well we we already know that uh right
across the world we have seen uh for
example htv drivers um and it's not
unique to the uk a shortage of hgv
drivers as i say we are taking measures
to uh address that and you say about the
uh the prime minister uh traveling to
new york and a big part of the
uh the work he is going to do there is
actually to get the world focused on
some of the issues that we have to
address collectively to make sure that
we have things like food security in the
future and addressing uh climate change
is a really important part of that and
that's very much part of the
conversations that he'll be having over
in new york at the united nations
general assembly